I guess tonight is an actor and comedian
whose new podcast with Ken Jong is
called the darkest timeline
he's also the host of the tiger King and
I that's the after-show special for the
insanely popular Netflix documentary
Tiger King please welcome our good
friend Joel McHale Joel nice to see you
thank you
you look like DJ Jazzy Jeff you've got
you a nice there yeah no well this is
this is thank you this is my Star Trek
set but of course I got this at the
Funko pop store with your image on it
because I like to work out to it I like
to put this on for working out to know
what I'm trying to get away from you you
do more reps because like you're trying
to look at that shallow chest and yeah I
see I wouldn't say your chest is shallow
I would say it's concave nice sorry I'm
sorry that this is I want people to know
that that I'm not disabuse Aviv with you
I'm sorry pretty much this abusive with
me all the time that's but if it's any
consolation I'm the same with my kids
yes I've seen that I've seen you're very
verbally cruel you look great by the way
your hair is very naturally wonderful
and I'm jealous it's it's just a
flippy-floppy
thing that's all over the place and who
cares anymore
who cares do you I mean and I you the
makeup looks great no makeup this is no
makeup this is a ring light and look if
I got closer I won't it's too
frightening oh I thought you were like
doing a bit like a kabuki thing no this
is my actual skin tone it is yes wow
that's incredible how did your people
survive to this time I mean how did you
get most of them didn't actually and
they took one step outside that that hut
in Ireland and just burst into flame no
I'm probably built for quarantine really
shouldn't be outside okay let's say if
there was an apocalypse and you and I
for some reason were somehow we wound up
together we're separated from our
families but we have to be on the run
but we're here in Southern California
and all we have like is our clothes but
we do not have sunscreen what would we
do I would be dead in two hours we could
only travel at night you do better than
me I think you have a little dark Irish
in you I you would smell what you
thought was cooking pork look over and
you'd see a little smoldering smudge
with a little bit of tuft of orange hair
and then you would taste it for the
nutrients and then you would run 60
miles and find shelter oh so you're
gonna be fun we have much to talk about
yes I've been busy tiger king and I yeah
this is a major phenomenon that the the
tiger king is massive I think it's one
of the biggest documentary explosions in
certainly recent memory it's been a
gusher for Netflix then they decide to
do a show talking about that show and
interviewing some of the people from the
show and you get to host it that's
fantastic how did this happen uh well I
I don't know I think Ted Saran does who
runs Netflix lost a bet of some sort no
I did was Ted Saran DOS yeah I worked
for Netflix a couple times and I had a
show on there at one point and he was
just very nice and I'll and asked me if
I would do it and to which I did you
know I looked like I was a Lucy sketch
saying yes and I because I was like I
liked the sea reason to be you know to
just have a tiny little part in it and
interview some of these people was
really fun and then people gave me such
[ __ ] for asking of Joe exotic should be
in jail right and I was like that
doesn't seem like a real hard-hitting
guy who thought that was a rude question
they were like how dare you how dare you
and I was like 19 felonies
animal Hughson and they it was a weird
thing because I think people see them as
characters and not necessarily as human
beings
one of the things I had questions I had
for you was you know you actually
getting to talk to these people and be
around them a lot do you find yourself
starting to empathize with them a little
bit to the point that you think hey I've
got a little property I could have I
could own a tiger do you see yourself
going that way in the near future
uh I yes I only want like tigers that
are two and a half years old I want them
to be full-grown young and very
dangerous and let them out anywhere
really I mean why not I want to be the
guy in LA whose nun who has incredibly
old Tigers like Tigers that have what
they've lost their teeth are about I
don't know how long a tiger lives but
they're like in their late 60's and
they're losing they've lost chunks of
hair I would go to the zoo they sit
around my house all day long and they
just we feed them soup that's that those
are the Tigers I want I would that zoo
ship would be popular I think could you
imagine like the tour guide I'm just
going well that's Benny and he's still
asleep and he's been sleeping for 15
hours and then also no danger and no
think about that that zoo in tiger king
is there constantly having to feed them
massive amounts of protein this any time
I go to them with a bowl of soup the
tiger would be like a little nauseous
I'll be like all right all right let me
know and I'll let you know then you come
back he's like it's your favorite it's
the soft noodles you've been doing some
promotion and I want you to explain this
okay viral online this is you promoting
this show and is this is that your your
body and then I believe you looks like
you've shaved your lower area and
written Netflix down towards the yeah I
shaved my entire body twice a day cuz it
grows so fast yeah I'm sorry I just yeah
look what is that what am I this is
pornography how dare you some people
like to promote their shows and I've
heard and so I look you've been as you
know you've been on television since
1955 when you took over for Steve Allen
yeah and I this is my one shot and so
does cut to me at 8 o'clock or 9 o'clock
in a bathroom trying to write netflix on
my stomach you did this
you wrote this yourself I did I shot
that alone in a room like a serial
killer and I felt very much like it was
silence at the lamps and then the next
day my kids saw me with my shirt off and
it said a Netflix still because I was
proud and they didn't even say anything
yeah I spent a lot of time telling
people you know what a bad guy you are
thank you are doing something very nice
very cool to help out local Los Angeles
restaurants right now once you tell us
what you're doing yes well I will say
well I started because again I an
extreme extrovert and have to get out so
and I knew a bunch of local restaurants
here in the valley where I live and and
they were still open and so I just I
just started filming myself outside of
the restaurants with fully naked no I
and I would just say hey go to go to
tuning fork here in Studio City it's a
great gastropub and and and then and and
promote them and then and this is for
take out this is for take you know
obviously you can't go in yeah and
they're all still working they're all
being very sanitary except for one and I
won't tell you who and then it's very
dangerous there no and then Melissa
McCarthy name-drop Ben Falcone name drop
October act oh they contacted me and
said hey that's really cool you're doing
we just talked to Octavia Davis and
again name drop and Octavia Spencer dear
God sorry
what [ __ ] anyway they were like she's
been feeding hospitals and wit by buying
meals and we should combine powers and
get money from those independent reps or
get food from their pay those
restaurants and then serve hospital
staffs who are obviously overworked and
so then we were start trying to start a
free like a nonprofit and then we heard
about this thing called frontline foods
which they've already got a huge
infrastructure they're already doing it
and we just kind of joined forces with
them and that's why I'm talking about it
now and I if they're in many cities and
so these there are so many independent
businesses that are gonna go down and
even with government help which is great
but they're still they're gonna there
are so many people are gonna lose their
jobs and they're not paying rent right
now which is great but soon as this is
over they're gonna be on the hook for it
so anything anybody can do out there to
support your local restaurants or any
local business like that you definitely
should like Conan you should definitely
have another bus of like one of the
Roosevelts maybe put in FDR there you
know you can keep doing my part I've
been going to hospitals and shouting
monologue jokes through the open windows
oh I've been arrested six times
apparently that was a terrible idea well
but it it's not really giving back it
was I thought it was I thought I heard
that laughter was the best medicine so
that's what I did and then it turned out
that it's it's terrible idea the jokes
weren't good my delivery was off and you
had this even after five times you
thought I'm gonna do it again I'm just
gonna try again I'm tenacious when it
comes to giving okay well you you should
support your local independently owned
businesses and it gots a better way to
go yeah don't do what I was doing do you
have any of my knives near you I don't
have any near me I have a knife near me
that but I don't have any of your knives
near me that you've given me over the
years this is the blade I've been
sporting this is
it's nice I just like the like the that
is nice cute own nine expensive knife
just got it online you should have
called me I would have sent you some
you're always giving me knives it's mine
that's what I wanted it's my job I know
but the problem is some sometimes people
find the knives you give me and they get
disturbed like for Christmas you gave me
a pair of brass knuckles yes run my desk
and people have picked them up and they
go at what is this and I go oh those are
brass knuckles and they think I'm a pimp
in my spare time so what's the problem
not a problem at all I have now a very
good business that's even now yeah sure
no never
now more than ever people longed to be
touched when was the last time you punch
someone let's see what today today's
today's yeah be like 1976 Oh a bit a
while ago yeah on the set of Saturday
Night Fever no I was not on the movie
sir no I was a child then okay
yeah but that's who'd you punch she was
younger she was much younger than me oh
man about five oh that's from the back
of the head
and that's terrible so if she's five and
this is 1976 so you're like 33 or 34 I
was in my early 40s mm-hmm you look
amazing
thank you a lot of work done hey I want
to mention something you have a new
podcast thank you with Ken Jong yes I
didn't give it to you it's just your
podcast oh and you talked about
everything on this from you'll talk
about episodes of community but you'll
also talk about coronavirus you come
yell ken is a real doctor or he used to
be before he is he how dare you he I'm
sorry but so it so he's a dr. Phil he's
a dr. oz I mean no doctors out there
spouting [ __ ] and now I'm supposed
to believe that
and Ken Jong's a real doctor well he
went to Duke Medical School he was a
practicing medical doctor so I know that
I don't think dr. Phil's an actual
medical doctor I think dr. oz is a
doctor cuz he wears those blue that blue
outfit he just bought that at a
Halloween store oh well okay I felt
mustache went to college he did not
parent you dirty crack [ __ ] uh that's
the that's the way I know Ken's a real
he really was I don't think he's a I
don't think he was good at it I mean
that's why he went into entertainment
and now ken is very old and needs work
and needs to be needs to keep his brain
going and so I would talk to him about
the coronavirus and his wife is a
practicing doctor Tran Tran ho really is
a practicing doctor and she this is her
hobby has been infectious diseases and
stuff like this and so I was like we
should go talk about it because Ken's
really good at distilling it and then of
course we knew there would be community
questions in Episode four were you
wearing a yet and so that's yeah we just
had Alison Brie on and she's cool
she's ugly and not funny um well listen
again you're showing your true nature
not a good guy
hmm you're you're always very busy in
addition to making rap albums in you yep
I got to dropping tomorrow as your hands
doing you also have a Mortal Kombat
movie coming out yes I played Johnny kid
the voice of Johnny Cage I can't play
the actual Johnny Cage that'll be
probably Ryan Reynolds well then when
will we ever go out to dinner again and
have wine and just chat will that ever
happen again
I think restaurants will open and people
will gather again and have wine you and
I will not get together what well we
can't after this you I asked you on my
show and you show up in a bathroom with
headphones on but look this that's you
with you that's you that's a knockoff
you have a respirator here
help you that's my respirator that's the
work that's getting anyone excited about
Kona that I feel like it just shows you
he doesn't stop he keeps going it's
going he's got a respirator he won't
he's amazing
I mentioned this Joel's podcast the
darkest timeline is available wherever
you get your podcasts yeah and the tiger
King and I is streaming now on netflix
and I don't think you can help but see
it you must see it I agree I'll see it I
didn't have much to do with it but I'm
happy to hitch my wagon to it I think
it's a good that's sort of my attitude
about a lot of things in the business
you know that was my attitude about
heroin okay you went too far you're
right you know what you're right all
right I'm ending this because no you
will not go on I'm gonna scratch let's
keep going I feel like this is the only
way I can end any interview it's because
when I look in the mirror do you do the
thing I do which is burst out crying and
then hit it no just smash it no I start
I kiss the tips of my fingers then I go
like this and I go I get to be me I get
to be me man
the self-confidence is incredible man
you're just thinking about her right now
well I you know the other thing about
zoom is I can I haven't looked at you
once this interview really I'm looking
at me and you know it's great I get to
be me yeah who are you talking to who
are you looking at I'm just looking at I
have an imaginary crowd I'm in like a
stadium